without a family man alone in the world
trembles with the cult when the old one
was awakened the deep fog spread of the
world and from the fog came demons a
horde that swept through boletaria
and brought civilization to its knees
the old one is a bottomless pit of
nothingness with an insatiable appetite
for souls but it cannot collect Souls
itself imagine a tree with roots leaves
and a core the old one is the trunk the
core of the tree it spreads its roots
into the lands full of humans and the
fog drains their souls as a creatures
soul diminishes they become soul starved
paranoid insane and full of Rage the mad
attacked the sane and chaos prevails the
only way to stay saying is to collect
Souls and so souls become the only valid
currency in boletaria
those who feed on human souls or pledge
themselves to the old one become demons
reflecting myth and the person or thing
that they were before take the major
demon phalanx it is the corrupted soul
form of a longbow sniper Alon who fought
from a distance and never put her life
on the line a coward
and so demons begin to take over
infecting the world spreading the fog
and wiping out humanity a man named
Thomas lived near the palace with his
wife and daughter before the scourge
came his equipment suggests that he was
a hunter and perhaps this is how he
provided for his family in the Nexus
however he took up a new profession
I'm stopped by old Thomas when the
scourge came I abandoned my wife and
daughter and Freud like a madman when I
came to I was in the Nexus I haven't
dared venture outside these walls since
sometimes I stop and wonder
how I ended up with a Nexus of the first
place
why didn't I protect my wife and
daughter even if it meant being slaying
by the demons please forgive me I am
over it now with no formal combat
training and no courage in the face of
the demons Thomas left his wife and
daughter behind instead fleeing from the
scourge taking over the boat Aryan
Palace he accepts himself as weak and
puts his hope instead into the demon
slayers who venture outside the safe
walls of the Nexus this rejuvenating
sanctorium is a fine place for the
Slayers of demons arrest their weary
balls I too must contribute how I can
for we are indebted to our honorable
defenders true to his new name stock pal
Thomas lightens the loads of the demon
hunters who come through the Nexus
looking after any excess baggage they
might have until they return what is the
world like outside the Nexus with brave
souls like you confronting these vile
demons perhaps it won't be long before
things return to normal at least that is
what we are all praying for he cannot
know for sure whether his wife and
daughter fell at the hands of the demons
maybe they found refuge somewhere maybe
they're being held prisoner Thomas has
no closure alas his wife and daughter
did die at the hands of the demons he
find two corpses suspended by chains
from the side of a tower in the palace
on one of the bodies you find a jade
hair ornament which identifies her as
Thomas's daughter the other wears
raggedy robes and carries fresh spice a
consumable item used by magicians it's
unknown why the demon singled out his
family to be hung most corpses are left
on the ground perhaps it's because there
were women or perhaps they were
identified as witches and suffered at
the hands of the fat ministers before
they
either way you return the hairpin to
Thomas
confirming the death of his family that
hair appeal that belongs to my daughter
then she didn't make it after at all my
dearest little baby may she rest in
pieces poor Thomas can let go now with
the knowledge that his wife and daughter
are at peace nothing can be done for
them so the coward focuses on giving you
his support for you fight on his behalf
you're a saint
thank you thank you so much how do you
do it I can't imagine what it takes to
slay a demon if only I had that kind of
strength
if only I could assist in this fight you
have a heart of gold don't let them take
it from you
on the first day man was granted a soul
and with a clarity foreign man great
potential was seen yet
on the second day upon earth was planted
an irrevocable poison a soul devouring
demon for like the demon man had an
insatiable destructive appetite for
souls for power